Iran is one of the country's most
impacted by coronavirus add to this the
fact that they have been isolated from
the international market for more than
two years with economic crises and
without the ability to make
international transactions we have
colossal humanitarian distress it's not
just that they have thousands of
infected people there are fewer
resources to treat the sick than any
European country faced with such a
situation both Hassan rouhani and
Ayatollah Khamenei II tried to hide the
problem until it was too late as if that
were not enough Iran has rejected
international aid both from the United
States and from NGOs and Doctors Without
Borders in other words Iran wants to
solve the biggest health crisis of the
21st century on its own despite having
no means to do so so why do we say that
Iran is failing in its fight with
coronavirus what consequences can covert
19 have for the ayatollah regime well
that's exactly what we're gonna be
covering in today's video this trans
when you see on screen is the spokesman
for the government of Iran in this press
conference he is talking about how the
country has coronavirus under control
he's telling the Iranians that they have
nothing to worry about there's no
problem however the man who is sweating
behind him is a Raja ricci the deputy
minister of health care and of course
you'll say well why is this man sweating
so much oh you guessed it he has a fever
and the next day he tested positive for
corona virus
these images are from mid-february 2020
at the time we're making this video
Iran was already one of the countries
most affected by coronavirus official
figures speak of more than four thousand
deaths but there could be many many more
[Music]
however it is only now that the
government has decreed a quarantine in
other words it is one of the countries
that has taken the longest time to react
to the corona virus pandemic the
ayatollahs regime has expelled all the
NGO Doctors Without Borders from the
country and this is in a country that is
practically isolated from the world so
what's going on in Iran
how far can a country so damaged by
coronavirus go could this be the ends of
the ayatollahs well watch this space
[Applause]
[Music]
the year 2020 has been tough on Iran the
murder of general Soleimani is the crash
of the Ukrainian Airlines plane and now
coronavirus Iran theses catastrophic
death toll from coronavirus DW at the
time we're recording this video there
were already 23 ministers infected and
several government officials who have
died in the city of Guam they have had
to dig mass graves to bury the hundreds
of bodies that the virus leaves behind
every day and all many of you will say
Spain literally also suffering something
similar and swell yet you're right
however the case of Iran is particularly
serious
think about it this country has been in
a brutal economic crisis for more than
two years Donald Trump's economic
sanctions almost completely isolated the
entire country that means they can
barely buy respirators masks and all the
medical equipment needed to treat the
sick and yes it's true economic
sanctions do not affect medical products
but how can I run by them if they can't
afford them if you remember in other
videos on visual politic we've already
explained how Iran is cut off from the
Swift system which is the system that
allows you to make international
transactions in other words Iran has
little means to treat it stick in the
face of this situation it would be
normal to ask for help
wouldn't it countries companies NGOs in
a crisis situation we should all unite
to defeat coronavirus well the Iranian
regime doesn't think so
[Music]
brainian authorities revoke approval for
MSF coronavirus treatment center MSF
that's right Iran is rejecting the help
of an NGO they have also refused US aid
Iran's regime wants to solve coronavirus
on its own and the truth is they don't
seem to have a very clear plan of action
you see it's a leader creed national
confinement when they had nine thousand
people infected Spain declared an alarm
status with five thousand two hundred
infected other countries were more
cautious such as the Czech Republic
which began implementing measures went
there were not even a hundred cases of
infection well at the time of making
this video Iran's official figures
claimed there are more than 65,000
confirmed cases of corona virus and
still the government has not yet
declared any type of quarantine at least
not during the making of this way
as you can imagine one of the main
reasons they do not want the country to
stop is summed up in one word economics
Iran has been virtually ruins for years
in this situation the last thing they
want is to curb the little productive
muscle they have left now the price
they're going to pay is very high you
see by now we've learned a lot of things
about pandemics and we already know that
the later the measures are put in place
a harder it is to slow the progress of
an epidemic so you can imagine the
problem they're having in Iran and all
the worst is yet to come so the question
is are they at least going to be able to
save their economy even if it comes at
an enormous human cost and why is Iran
turning a blind eye to the biggest
health crisis of the 21st century and
not only that could this crisis mean the
end of the ayatollahs well today we're
going to answer these questions but
before we do let's take a look back
a self-sufficient country I'm gonna ask
you a question which stock market do you
think had the largest increase in 2019
someone say New York or London or
Singapore
well actually it was none of them the
answer is the Tehran stock exchange
that's right the Iranian exchange took
off last year but now you gotta be
wondering well how is that possible
because reality is 2019 was pretty
terrible for Iran give you an idea in
2018 this country exported three million
barrels of all the day a year later the
numbers fell to less than half a million
barrels all of this is due to the
sanctions the United States put in place
sanctions that also forced European
companies to leave the country
Jena Vodafone PSA had to abandon all of
their Iranian investments inflation
exceeded 40 percent some basic shopping
commodities doubled their prices the
government had to raise taxes the
Iranians took to the streets look it's
been an economic debacle
in every crisis however there are people
who benefit and one of the great
beneficiaries in this story was the
Iranian stock exchange I think that the
Iranian currency the rial was worth less
than monopoly money so no one kept their
savings in the bank and where did they
put it well in the only stock market
where they could invest that is the
local stock market the Tehran stock
market but not only that the government
started making moves to stop relying on
oil at all costs and in a way they did
it yes Iran has much more to offer the
world than just barrels of oil for
example see that plastic covering on
your mobile charger cable well that's
called polyethylene it turns out that
Iran is one of China's leading suppliers
of polyethylene that means it's likely
that if your mobile charger is made in
China that the cable plastic is actually
made in Iraq
but not only this in other videos we've
already told you about Iran Khodro
Iran's national car brands because yes
Iran makes its own cars so in the
absence of major international brands
like Renault or Kia Quadro has been
doing a roaring trade they've gone from
making six hundred cars a day to more
than 2,000 of course this has been done
with the help of the government and
these cars have been exported to
neighboring countries countries like
Iraq Armenia and Azerbaijan to avoid
sanctions many entrepreneurs have been
going to Turkey with briefcases full of
cash to open their companies there from
Turkey they can make international
transactions and sell their products
[Music]
in 2019 alone Iranian entrepreneurs
registered 2,000 companies on Turkish
soil and many other sectors have been
consolidated according to the Financial
Times 70% of the medical equipment used
in Iran is now produced in Iran itself
in other words yes Iran's exports have
plummeted but thanks to China and
neighboring countries Iran has been able
to survive of course it's a subsistence
economy but it could be a lot worse and
that's when we come to thee epidemic in
the sanctuary city the city of bomb is
one of the religious capitals of Shia
Islam every year more than 20 million
pilgrims visit the sanctuary of Fatima
in the city China is building a
high-speed train at a solar plant and
you probably thinking right now well
fascinating Simon but why are you
telling me this well you're about to see
why on february 4th 2020 iran canceled
flights to china to prevent coronavirus
infection however the government turned
a blind eye to one airline Mahon air as
you can imagine iran was not in a
position to stop the travel of chinese
entrepreneurs but well the story doesn't
end there
On February 15th ayatollah khamenei ii
held a religious gathering in the city
of qualm in principle everything was
normal except for one thing the
Ayatollah did not allow anyone to kiss
his hands and you're probably thinking
well did he know some things that others
didn't well yes
[Music]
it turns out that no less than 700
Shiite clerics of Chinese origin
attended this event four days later the
Iranian government confirms the first
two deaths by covet 19 from the city of
Quan according to local politicians
these deaths were actually reported
several days earlier as you can imagine
at this point the Iranians are beginning
to worry the authorities were as well so
on if everything's focused Minh gave a
press conference at their press
conference he said there was nothing to
worry about the government had
controlled all centers of infection and
there was no need to impose a quarantine
however the deputy minister of health
care who was by his side already had the
first symptoms of covert 19
[Music]
so what was the government's policy well
Ronnie's government set out to try to
solve the most pressing problem of all
the most urgent the one which absolutely
must be avoided in a pandemic fake news
that's right On February 29th
cybercrime police arrested 24 people for
spreading alleged hoaxes and conspiracy
theories meanwhile the Iranian
authorities were continually
contradicting themselves for example
remember the shrine of Fatima in the
city of Guam that we just talked about
well the director of that shrine
continued to call on all Shiite pilgrims
to go there and pray his arguments was
well what better place to heal than a
sacred sanctuary by now Iran had 245
infected almost all of which were in the
city of war the mayor is asking
permission to shut the city down but the
government wasn't responding at least it
didn't give a clear answer what's more
if you look at news from that time
you'll find conflicting messages on the
one hand rouhani said he was considering
a quarantine throughout the whole
country but not yet meanwhile the number
of confirmed cases kept growing but hold
on a minute because that wasn't even the
biggest problem earlier that Iran has
been isolated from the international
market for two years
if European countries struggling to buy
masks respirators and tests imagine a
country that can't even make financial
transactions and well this is when we
get to America
the Yankees are to blame
so who isolated Iran for international
markets the United States and who can
help Iran get respirators and
coronavirus tests well that would be the
United States all of this explains why
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo offered
help to Iran at least that's what the
White House says meanwhile Congress
discussed the possibility of removing
sanctions from Iran
ohhohh Omar who is a Democratic
congressman proposed to take them away
all together Republicans refused the
truth is it doesn't matter who won the
debate Ayatollah Khamenei II had already
made a decision
Iran leader refuses us help sites
coronavirus conspiracy theory Ayatollah
Ali Khamenei alleges virus is
specifically built for Iran using the
genetic data of your onions al Jazeera
it's exactly as it sounds
in case anyone doubts the source that
news story is from Al Jazeera which is
not an anti Iranian media outlet or
anything like that and I know what a lot
of you are gonna be thinking you got a
point at the end of the day it's to be
expected that Iran doesn't trust the
United States which is its archenemy but
then to everyone's surprise ourselves
included comes this news
[Music]
it just doesn't make sense that is
Doctors Without Borders an NGO based in
Switzerland they've been helping
humanitarian missions around the world
so why weren't Iran take their help I
don't get it
and the truth is that the situation
especially in the city of Quan is far
from under control look at this
[Music]
satellite images show Iran has built
mass graves amid coronavirus outbreak
The Guardian now you might be thinking
well okay from a humanitarian point of
view this is a failure but have they at
least managed to save their economy well
the truth is no Iran's few remaining
trading partners have closed the borders
with the country and yes that also
includes China as if this were not
enough the government has ended up
locking down all their cities at this
point in time
Iranians cannot travel from one city to
another and it is very likely that by
the time you're watching this video they
will have already decreed an official
quarantine in other words the Iranian
economy is going to end up stopping at a
point when it's almost impossible to
curb the infection rate
[Music]
so what about the regime will ayatollah
khamenei be able to save face and think
about this carefully Khamenei is eight
years old
that is isn't the group that is most at
risk of dying of coronavirus and even if
the regime is doing everything it can to
protect you from infection invisible
enemies are really hard to avoid look at
this
adviser to Iran's supreme leader
infected with coronavirus reuters so now
the question is over to you do you think
this will be the end of the ayatollahs
regime will Iran be able to get to the
respirators and medical equipment it
needs to avoid a massive disaster why
are they refusing all outside help well
leave your answer in the comments below
and I really do hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit like if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also please do check out our
friends at reconsider media it provided
the vocals in this episode that we're
not mine and as always thank you for
watching if you want to learn more about
politics and world affairs and here's
some more of my lovely voice come check
out the reconsidered podcast where we
don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider @ww re consider mediacom or
on apple or google play or your favorite
podcast
[Music]